here's some terrible copyrighting advice
I've gotten for writing emails be
yourself be authentic what no no when I
write emails I use a strategy called U
plus two meaning take your natural
personality and crank it up to notches
so it is you but more exaggerated to the
to the next level okay so think about
when Kevin Hart steps on stage on the
platform he's telling personal stories
but they're exaggerated they're more
entertaining he's doing the motions and
all of these things you are like Kevin
Hart you're an Entertainer but via email
you are competing with Tik Tok and
Reddit threads and YouTube videos and
all these other sorts of things so you
have to entertain via email which means
you need to be entertaining so don't
take your natural self Crank It Up A
Notch and I bet people start loving your
emails and your copy more